hey hopefully we see you on a basketball
court again
yeah it's very
possible i feel like the lakers is a
very very serious candidate to bring
iman trumper back to the league
it would make sense you have so many
friends on the team you bring a set of
skills that they need it's crazy
sometimes i'll be feeling like i'll be
like man after a while they just gonna
have me sit there and they gonna want me
to be an announcer or some [ __ ] bro
cause i'm like [ __ ] wanna talk
about it with me so much i'm like can i
put one thing into the world i'd like to
see in the next five years i wanna see
you and j.r smith do a podcast together
oh that was going to happen eventually
anyway not an actual like you mean like
the way all the smoke is or yeah or like
yeah
oh that'd be must-see tv in fact if you
guys were living in the same city and
you guys could do a podcast once a week
once a month swish i ain't doing [ __ ]
that is i'm telling you that is a bag
that is swiss i ain't doing [ __ ] boy you
guys better go tap in with bill simmons
at the ringer or somebody and they would
that is that is the pod
the iman and then swish podcasts you
guys just talk [ __ ] what
i'm actually doing the podcast my
podcast is uh is coming so that's coming
yeah yeah it's with me and my brother
though okay um but
me and my brother is probably uh
that's probably gonna be your best look
at barbershop talk okay because my
brother is like he's like you he plays
the fan
the fan uh card but he like it's like
serious oh yeah listen man it's like no
[ __ ] you like it's like that
i am extremely invested in sports i
gamble every [ __ ] day i love you i
have the league pass
i do i got to say that too though cause
i talk [ __ ] about fans that go out of
their way and say a lot of [ __ ] but it's
like without these fans talking [ __ ] and
creating the energy a lot of the
basketball that we play ain't the same
like you need them hecklers you need it
like
it's all part of it it all adds to the
energy it's all good like for 48 minutes
hate me bro